Point, Steven.
It helps if I unmute.
Mm.
Yep, I hear you now. How are we doing?
I am doing great.
How's Alaska treating you?
Ohh.
So yesterday it hit 75, which is probably... Actually, let me tell you.
And.
23 Celsius.
33 Celsius, that's good. I mean, as per last, I think it's hot.
Das.
Yeah.
But as for our side of the world, that's that's.
Atul.
Haha.
Better, better than most of the temperatures that we have in India. We are experiencing 45 to 48 degrees Celsius.
So...
Ooh.
And imagine almost, not almost, double of it.
Exactly.
No way. Doesn't normally get that high though. It usually stays between like 20, 21 in the summer. So it's also early June, so it's a little weird for it to be so warm. Normally it's like end of June, beginning of July when it gets this warm. So season's a little weird.
Yeah.
We are near the equator, so you know, for us, the temperature rises like this, and I think it's El Nino's year, so the temperature is rising abnormally.
Ahh.
It's super, I read it in news, so...
Anyways, uh, how are things going at computer?
Good. I finally got notice for two of our customers that were acquired by, you know, parent companies that they are ending services with us. They were a month apart from each other. We thought they'd leave six months ago, but they didn't. So, I mean, we're lucky to have kept them the extra five months. But one just gave us their 30 days and the other one just
I.
hit the end of their 30 days on June 1st. So we're two clients less, but we're also looking at three to four customers that we might be onboarding here soon. So not quite where we were. Those were two pretty decent customers, like 80 devices each, but it's okay.
That's great.
That's just how it is.
Other than that, just...
Same day-to-day stuff as usual. We get tickets, we do the tickets, we help people, they get happy, we go home.
Yeah.
Yep, that's what we are for.
Mm.
All right, that's great. And how are things going with Arkadi?
Hoh.
To be honest, he's been pretty.
I mean, he's been great. He just, he's been pretty independent this month. I haven't really, he's just been, when he hasn't had anything, he just picks up tickets and has been doing them. He has a pretty good feel for what he can or cannot do. And then he has a couple projects. Like we have one that we're going to be giving him here soon. Just not ready yet because we're not ready to.
start on it yet. And then I have another one that I'm going to give him probably in about a month, or he's going to end up logging into all of our customers and accepting GDAP agreements. Because we just switched licensing vendors. So that was fun. But.
Yeah, I think he's doing server maintenance right now if he didn't just finish it.
Okay.
Thank you so much. Did I tell you that we all went on to the team outing last month? So...
But.
Noise.
I think you mentioned it was going to happen.
Yep, so Arnie was a part of it. So actually we traveled to the mountains. There is this hill station that's called Rani Keith. So, you know, that's the place where we all went and it was a great time. We had to hike. It was like almost 60 degrees.
Mm.
hiking and it was a good time. We tested our lungs there because complete 8 hours of the day, you know, we are sitting on a chair and working on IT stuff. This is when we went into the wilderness and hiking and went on to the cottages. So that was a time when we realized, okay, this is something that we
Yeah.
need to take care of. Working is something which can, which is important, but physical is also required. So this was the realization that we had there. But all in all, it was a great party that we had in the night. Great fun.
Yeah, I uh, that's one of the main reasons I love Alaska, is just the hiking, the beauty, the outdoors. The problem is...
with my leg issues that I've been having. I just had surgery on April 22nd, I think you remember that. And my next one's next Thursday. So I get my left leg done next Thursday. And I actually have had a couple complications. Like I was just in the emergency room last week because I had a blood clot from the surgery on the right leg. And they gave me a...
Yes, yep, yep.
a stroke level 1 alert. So they said it passed, but like that came out of nowhere. I thought I'm getting better and then all of a sudden it's like, oh, okay.
Sorry.
But...
You know, hopefully all this is worth it and I can go out and start hiking again because I'm going to go crazy if I can't do anything but work.
Yeah, I mean, for us, the things in India are a little different. You know, we, I think this is this is how things are in India. We prefer work over everything, but this is something that we realize when we cross our 30s or in mid 30s.
And.
and realize again when our bodies start to talk to each other, talk to us, where, you know, that, hey, you need to focus on the physical fitness too. So I think that that outing that happened last month was the milestone and turning point where
we have this realization and now we will start visiting places more frequently where we would have something to do physically rather than just sitting on a chair and working on ITBD stuff.
Good.
100% agree.
Yeah.
All right, that's great. Any feedback that you have for Arkadi that he needs to work on, needs to improve on?
Nope.
No issues. I mean, he just does what you give him, which I can't say for everybody here, but I mean, he does, so...
I appreciate it, Stephen. Thank you so much. And did you receive the CSAT survey for the month of May?
I...
Don't know.
Let me look.
May was a rough month.
And.
Yep.
I don't know that I got it from what I'm looking at. And we did do a lot of spam filter changes.
Because we are trying to get, so we have customers who send us like actual phishing emails to ask if they're phishing. And we were trying to allow basically more emails to come through even when they're obviously bad, because apparently we are smart enough to not click them.
And.
through that adjustment, things with small message bodies, because the CSAT emails, they just have like the click the link and they're very small and minimal. That might have got caught in the new filter because I don't see it at all. I see the previous one for April, but I do not see May's.
Yeah.
Well, I have just re-triggered the C side survey, so you should receive it in the next minute or two.
And.
Tell you what, let me just whitelist ITBD.net.
Okay.
Because I still don't have it.
No, but.
Yep, spam.
Kip.
A little spam.
It is now, yeah, because it's just a link with a small body. Let me...
Okay, release.
Yeah, we did a lot of changes to our spam filter.
Okay.
So now you have the email, right?
Yes.
submitted.
Eject.
All right, yep, I see things up. Thank you so much for that.
Rick.
Okay, I guess things are moving well with Army and he's doing a pretty good job. If there are any other issues or concerns that you have, Stephen, please feel free to email me and I'll be more than happy to help you. Before we call it a meeting, is there anything else that I should be aware of?
Nope.
I think it's been almost a year, right?
Yeah, it will be in a few days, and yep.
So the year passed, just like that.
I know, I still remember my first call with Ben. I think he was sitting in his house and he was someone who said that I don't believe in having the service calls. So usually what happens in ITBD design is, you know, the first three months we keep.
Haha.
Service calls on a weekly momentum to ensure that engineers are settled. But I think after two weeks, then he said, okay, let's move this call to months. I was like, okay, okay, we'll do that.
I mean.
For us specifically, that just fits more, because like we not, I mean, there's no issue. And if there was an issue, we would have just emailed you and said, hey, there's an issue. So you can just assume that silence means good.
Hmm.
Yeah, I mean, it is good that you that you think it that way, but you know, most of the people don't think like that, especially here, you know, so if if it's if there is no news, then that means something is not right, so...
Mm.
Yeah, mindset.
at times and it is considered as, yeah, you're right, the right word, mindset, correct.
We're pretty easygoing compared to most people.
All right, well, Steven. Yeah, I mean, trust me, you are, you are. With Arnie, you know, I talk to him and I tell him, see, you are lucky that you are working with computer Vivus. I have, you know, other engineers as well, and trust me.
Yeah.
When things go south, they are crazy, just crazy. So you are, I mean, sorted, organized, supportive. What else I can say?
It.
Thank you.
Both, yeah.
No.
All right, well, Stephen, it was nice talking to you. We will meet next month and I will reach out to you in between regarding...
Yeah.
the upcoming holiday of July 4th.
That, yep.
That's going to be, so we are observing an off on 3rd of July because 4th being the weekend. So let me just ask you, since you are here on the call, would you require Arnie available on 3rd of July or is this something that he can take an off?
Mm.
That's fine.
He can totally take that day off. The other thing is on July 1, I'm going to be out, which is our next meeting. My parents are actually visiting, so I'm going to be off that whole week.
Yep.
That's nice.
Yeah, they've never come to Alaska before. They live in a different state, and I haven't seen my parents in about 5 years. So Alaska is on their bucket list, and they want to come up here. They have some medical concerns and stuff, so they've just not been able to, and they finally saved up. And it's definitely something I want to take time off for.
Ohh, that's long.
because I don't want to have my attention for them on the one time they're going to come up here.
Yeah, totally understand.
Um...
But if we can move that to the 8th, and that should work, if that's possible.
Yep, I will do that. Thank you so much.
Key.
From first time over to it, and uh...
For 3rd of July, our needs is open to take you off, right?
That's fine, yes.
Okay.
And make them quite updates.
Thank you so much, Dipon, for sharing it.
and I'll see you on July 8th. So until then, please take care of yourself and I wish you a great time with your family.
Thank you.
You're welcome. Have a good one.
You too. Bye.
Bye.